welcome everyone and thank you for
joining for this special event
today we celebrate the 30th anniversary
of the nih office of research on women's
health
and we mark the many accomplishments and
remaining challenges of women's health
research
i'm often asked what is the story behind
orwh
even on an elevator where 20 second
answers are due rigor i can't help
wanting to reply
how many floors are you going
there's simply so much to our story its
history is rich and meaningful it's
creation a combination of organic that
is in response to scientific knowledge
and community driven in response to an
era's reaction to inequities in society
orwh is organic in another way how it
responds and adjusts to the emergence of
new knowledge and diseases and changes
in society
in this slide i'm going to start our
chapter
talking about the founding of orwh and
the seeds for the office were planted
many years ago
it started with an awakening the civil
rights and women's rights movements of
the 1960s
with their concerns about social justice
and equality created fertile ground for
the rise of another movement the women's
health movement
women's and minority advocacy groups
drew attention to the inequities in
research and health care
in the early 1970s the boston women's
health book collective published the
profoundly influential book our bodies
ourselves
health healthcare activist billy avery
established what later become the black
women's health imperative
it drew attention to the ways the health
care system marginalized
african-american women
a series of drug recalls around the same
time revealed that many drugs pose
greater risks in women than men
moreover it became evident that nearly
all of the medicines on the market were
tested only in men
and that got congress's attention
members of the congressional caucus for
women's health issues weighed in
in particular senator barbara mikulski
and representatives
connie morell olympia snow and pat
schroeder
they push for increasing inclusion of
women as research participants
as well as expanding research on
diseases and conditions affecting women
also influential or patient advocacy
organizations research institutions
even medical societies and women's
health groups
finally the scientific community took
note of the gaps in medical research
research
more and more biomedical research was
finding sex differences and disease
manifestation and responses to treatment
the science could no longer be ignored
nor could the inequities in research and
health care
and nih responded led principally by
four forward-thinking leaders
dr edward brandt then assistant
secretary of health established the
public health service task force on
women's health issues
for its chair he appointed dr ruth l
kershteen
under her leadership the task force
advocated greater inclusion of women in
nih-funded clinical research it also
recommended more biomedical and
biobehavioral research be done on
conditions and diseases unique to or
more prevalent in women
in 1990 in response to growing concerns
about underrepresentation of women in
clinical studies on capitol hill and
elsewhere nih established orwh and
appointed dr kirstjeen acting director
very supportive of dr christine's
leadership over the following year was
newly appointed director of nih dr
bernadine healey who was a strong
advocate for women's health research
dr healey was the first and to date only
women to hold the position
and a year later dr vivian penn then
chair of pathology at howard university
college of medicine became the first
full-time director of the nih office of
research on women's health a position
she would hold until she retired in
2011.
let me take a moment and acknowledge the
contributions of everyone who played a
role in overwhelm's founding from these
visionary leaders at nih policymakers
advocates and other women and men who
pressed for an increase in women's
health research thank you
this next chapter of my presentation
will review just a handful of major
achievements in women's health of the
last 30 years
each of these examples happens to relate
to a disease or condition that is
specific to women
first the women's health initiative
a monumental undertaking launched in
1993 by dr bernadine healy with funding
from the national heart lung and blood
institute it was and is one of the
largest disease prevention and clinical
studies ever conducted on women's health
it's still contributing knowledge about
cardiovascular disease and aging
the women's health initiative or whi
found that menopausal hormone therapy
did not prevent heart disease in
postmenop post-menopausal women as once
thought
the whi demons at the use of estrogen
plus progestin hormone therapy after
menopause
increased the risk for heart disease
stroke
blood clots dementia and breast cancer
and an in-depth analysis for one of the
whi post-menopausal hormone therapy
trials has found that the investment in
whi
resulted in a return of 140
in net income value for each dollar
invested in the trial
i think you'll be hearing more about
maximizing roi in the future
around the same time in 1994 nih led the
discovery of the first gene shown to be
responsible for some inherited breast
and ovarian cancers
discoveries in breast cancer genetics
the whi results and other discoveries
have led to important improvements in
screening genetic testing
risk assessment models and clinical
management decisions they have helped us
make continuous progress on reducing
death rates due to breast cancer over
the past three decades
in 1992 the age-adjusted death rate due
to breast cancer in u.s women has fallen
had fallen from nearly 32 deaths per 100
000 women to about 20 per hundred
thousand putting this decline into
context take a look at the chart on the
right
it demonstrates just how dramatic a
decline that is for more than half a
century death rates were holding
relatively steady at about 30 to 35
deaths per hundred thousand
one of the most extraordinary
discoveries of the past 30 years is the
human papilloma virus vaccine
we have a vaccine against cancer
the hpv vaccination with booster shots
developed by nih offers durable
protection against the types of hpv
human papillomavirus that cause almost
all cervical cancer more exciting news
with cost and other barriers impeding
many from getting booster shots an ni
nci funded and orwh supported study is
testing a single dose vaccine
interim results indicate long-lasting
protection
this vaccine also benefits men more than
one-third of hpv-associated cancers are
diagnosed in males and more of half that
more than half of oropharyngeal cancers
are typed 16.
this next events
is not only important scientifically
it's pretty darn cool
in 2012 the national center for
advancing translational sciences
the defense advanced research projects
agency and the food and drug
administration began work on developing
3d chips with living cells and tissues
its goal to develop a device that can
more accurately model human organs
and the why
it is to address the high rate of
failure of candidate medications due to
toxicity or lack of efficacy when they
reach human trials
evatar was developed by the ncats team
and it's a miniaturized representation
of the female reproductive tract and
liver on an interconnected platform
besides testing candidate meds
medications evatar is being used to
model polycystic ovarian syndrome or
pcos
it could pave the way toward improved
reproductive health testing for
conditions like infertility
endometriosis uterine fibroids and
female cancers these are all very
important areas
my final example involves a recent
advance in a clinical application
postpartum depression is a mood disorder
that affects some women after childbirth
totally there was no treatment
specifically approved for postpartum
depression
many years of nih-funded research led to
the development of this breakthrough
drug
with fda approval of roxanna in 2019
from postpartum depression for the first
time ever had effective relief
these are just four examples over the
past 30 years
they represent the brilliance dedication
and inspiration of many scientists women
and men behind them
i would like to thank the investigators
who conceptualized these advances who
then validated tested and ultimately
executed on their designs
we have so much for which to be thankful
to them
it's not just through research that orwh
advances the health of
women i'm proud to say that orwh has
been a leader in implementing innovative
policies that have made a real
difference
the first is inclusion
which truly is in orwh's dna
for some background
for many years researchers typically did
not include women in clinical trials or
for that matter female animals in
pre-clinical research
there were a number of reasons
none of them good
researchers believe there were no
significant differences between males
and females other than their
reproductive functions
women especially pregnant women were
also considered a vulnerable population
that needed to be protected and their
valid concerns there
and another reason was the concern that
women's variable hormonal status could
not be adequately controlled for
unfortunately as a result
medications that were prescribed to
women were routinely tested in men in
other words unisex research
sex works in fashion sometimes and in
eyeglasses but not so well in biomedical
research
the omission of women from studies
created critical gaps in scientific
knowledge about conditions that affect
women more frequently than men or
differently it compromised our
fundamental understanding of female
biology
so beginning in the 1980s nih in
congress established formalized and
expanded inclusion policies to address
women and racial and ethnic minority
groups
more recently the 21st century cures act
expanded inclusion to include
individuals of all ages
it also cleared the path to including
pregnant and lactating women
two other policy developments are
helping to advance inclusion the cures
act also created an important mandate it
requires nih to find applicable phase 3
clinical trials to report their results
disaggregated by sex gender race and
ethnicity into clinicaltrials.gov
finally inclusion data for specific
disease groups are now reported by sex
gender race and ethnicity in the nih
research condition and diseases
categorization report
of course the 64 000 question is did nih
inclusion policy work
for the most part yes
today about half of nih supported
clinical trial and clinical research
participants are women
moreover women are less likely to
receive beneficial treatments than men
with cardiovascular disease
women who present with heart attack
symptoms are less likely than men to
receive fibrinolytic drugs stents and
related therapies
consistent with a lingering view that
obstructive coronary artery disease is
primarily a man's disease women with
this condition are less likely to
receive several of the indicated medical
treatments such as coronary
revascularization
statins beta blockers aspirin and even
therapeutic lifestyle coaching
the fact is that epidemiology symptoms
pathophysiology and outcomes of heart
disease differ between the sexes
have been underrepresented in these
areas of research often due to poorly
justified inclusion or exclusion
criteria including arbitrary participant
age limits
and women who are enrolled often do not
accurately represent the women in the
general population with the
cardiovascular conditions
so successful research and treatment of
diseases requires inclusion of
individuals representing the populations
with the highest disease burden this
must include equitable participation of
both sexes and all races and ethnicities
and sex and gender considerations must
be threaded throughout the entire
research continuum
this requires balanced mixed sex
research designs stratification of
samples bisects
analysis of data by sex and sex specific
reporting of results in both
pre-clinical translational and clinical
research
plus the pre-clinical research where the
building blocks of science are created
continues to over rely on male animals
finally there's been minimal progress in
one area where it really counts the
disaggregation analysis and reporting of
data by sex and publications
on this score there's so much work to be
done but more on that later
the second great innovation of the past
30 years has been the transformation of
the meaning of women's health for
decades women's health meant maternal
and reproductive health almost
exclusively bikini medicine they used to
call it with the rise of the women's
health movement the focus began to shift
or broaden
today the health of women encompasses
the whole woman from head to toe over
the life course
on a more fundamental level the approach
to the health of women took on a
multi-dimensional aspect
yes it includes biology
in but it also includes all diseases and
conditions that affect women it
recognizes that diseases manifestations
diagnoses and treatments might differ
for women but it also includes external
factors due to the important research
done by nih and others we now know that
the health of women is affected by many
factors that interact
not just the individual's biology or
genetics but her environment her
community and the larger society she
lives in
in fact we are increasingly discovering
how biological internal factors those at
the bottom of this graphic
intersect with the social and contextual
aspects found at the top of the graphic
moreover they affect a host of areas
such as health status disease
presentation and treatment response as
well as the effects of the diseases and
conditions on quality of life
the third innovative policy
may end up being the most
transformational
in the last 30 years research on women's
health has come a long way
women now make up half of the
participants of nih-funded studies and
we're making progress in the use of
female animals in pre-clinical research
but the inclusion of women in clinical
studies and the use of female animals in
pre-clinical research are just the
initial steps we now know sex affects
cell physiology metabolism and many
other fundamental biological functions
symptoms of disease and medication side
effects
but unless biomedical research accounts
for sex at every level from the
laboratory to the clinic you could say
that we are missing at least half of the
story
nih was also concerned about the lack of
reproducibility reported
so we heightened our focus on the need
for rigor and reproducibility and
transparency which
included the next big step in women's
health
five years ago
we issued a landmark policy that was
part of a global movement to integrate
the study of sex into the research
process
it states nih expects that sex as a
biological variable would be factored
into research designs analyses and
reporting
and vertebrate animal and human studies
unless a strong justification for single
sex study exists
accounting for sex as a biological
variable or sabv begins with the
development of the research question and
then the study design it also includes
data collection and analysis of results
as well as reporting findings
it's multifaceted with each facet as
important as the other
so why does it matter
considering sabv and pre-clinical
research and human trials stratifying
the data by sex and reporting results
will build a more complete knowledge
base which has important benefits
ranging from improving the design of
clinical research and trials informing
sex and gender aware diagnosis and
treatment enabling individualized
approaches for women and men and
fostering a system-based understanding
of sex and gender influences in health
and disease
and lrwh is taking a leading role in
implementing the nih sabv policy
across the enterprise one of the
principal ways is through resources
we at orwh are very pleased with three
recent additions to our
inter-professional education courses all
online and free i'll briefly mention two
of them
first is our bench to bedside
integrating sex and gender to improve
human health online course
developed in partnership with the fda's
office of women's health this six module
course gives users a thorough and
up-to-date understanding of sex and
gender influences on health and disease
today today bench to bedside has been
well received from september 1st to
december 1st 2020 we had over 750 unique
viewers to the orwh's courses web page
the second course is titled sex as a
biological variable primer
it was developed by orwh with funding
support for the national institute of
general medical sciences and a cadre of
subject matter experts
its four independent interactive modules
are designed to help the biomedical
research community including researchers
nih grant applicants and peer reviewers
account for and appropriately integrate
sabv across the full spectrum of
biomedical sciences
as i said earlier
women's health research is an nih-wide
endeavor
the principal way orwh supports and
funds research is through our signature
programs
each involves
research collaborations with the
institute centers and offices across nih
there's birch the building
interdisciplinary research careers and
women's health programs which celebrates
its 20th anniversary this year
this mentored career development program
connects junior faculty known as birch
scholars to senior faculty who shared
interest in women's health and sex
differences research
since 2000 88 grants to 44 institutions
supporting more than 700 junior faculty
have been awarded
second is score or the specialized
centers of research excellence on sex
differences program it's nih's only
disease agnostic center level sex
differences grant program
and then our sex and gender
administrative supplement program which
allows investigators to expand sex and
gender data adding to their existing
efforts
and finally nih's first ever r01 focused
on the intersection of sex and gender
influences in health and disease is now
entering year two
one of the greatest health challenges
facing the united states apart from the
coronavirus pandemic is the state of
maternal health
it's abysmal
our nation's maternal mortality rate
which continues to climb is the highest
among world's high income countries
whose rates are declining
tragically up to 60 of these deaths are
preventable in maternal health as in
other areas of research significant
disparities against exist among
populations of women
for example maternal mortality rates are
three times higher for black women than
white women
the situation regarding severe maternal
morbidity is equally dire it affects
over 50 000 women annually in the united
states at a rate that has nearly doubled
during the past decade
incidence incidence of severe maternal
morbidity among black women is
especially serious
compared to white women the rate for smm
is
166 percent higher for black women
nih's response to maternal health
disparities has been robust
here are just a few examples
the nih maternal mortality task force
has issued an initiative called improve
funding 7 million dollars in fy 20.
the idea states program
orwh partnered with nigms to expand
women's health research in idea states
the nimhd led r01 focused on maternal
health disparities and then orwh's own
u3 program understudied underreported
and underrepresented populations of
women provide support for maternal
health relevant topics as listed here
i would be remiss not to address nih's
response to kerbin 19.
we recently released the nih-wide
strategic plan for covet 19 research it
provides a much needed framework for
accelerating the development of
therapies vaccines and diagnostics
i call your attention to priority 5
which commits nih to addressing the
needs of health disparity and vulnerable
populations
specifically understanding and
addressing coping 19 as it relates to
these populations and understanding and
addressing coving 19 maternal health and
pregnancy outcomes
this is my last chapter of my
presentation and it focuses on careers
advancing women in biomedical careers
was one of our wh's original charges
from the nih and then later from
congress
this work began in earnest right away
with the creation of the reentry
supplements in 1992
perhap but perhaps one of the most
seminal moments in the history of orwh
was the release in 2008 of a specific
funding opportunity announcement the
causal factors and interventions for
women in biomedical and bioengineering
research rfa
never before had nih investigated why
women were neither entering nor
advancing in stem fields it was a bold
step but a natural one for nih
to assemble evidence of what barriers
exist
and what interventions work
as a result of this rfa the volume of
evidence expanded significantly the
effect of which was to accelerate change
in the workplace and academia
more recently the national academies of
science engineering and medicine report
on promising practices took the
discussion to another level
if we know what works then why aren't
institutions adopting these best
evidence-based practices
what are the institutional barriers and
what needs to be done to advance
specific groups like women of color
the last three decades we've seen
dramatic and exciting gains in women's
entry into scientific fields of study
as you can see here about half of all
medical degree and life sciences phd
recipients in stem fields are women
at the same time there's much more work
that needs to be done women continue to
face persistence and deep rooted
barriers to their advancement
in 2020 the nih working group on
biomedical careers
and the orwh undertook several major
initiatives two of which address
critical junctures in women's scientists
careers
the overarching goal of the continuity
supplements is to support the transition
and retention of investigators to
minimize departure of from departures
from biomedical research at these
critical junctures
one being the transition from a mentored
career development or k award to an
independent research project org and the
other being the transition from a first
independent research project award
to sustained funding in the form of a
first renewal or a second independent
research award
these programs are open to women and men
but because eligibility is tied to
critical life events during the project
period
events such as childbirth adoption and
primary caregiving responsibilities of
an ailing spouse child partner or member
of the immediate family these are
expected to improve the situation for
women scientists
the last major initiative is the
challenge prize called the nih prize for
enhancing faculty gender diversity in
biomedical and behavioral science
its goal is to recognize and disseminate
in transformative institutional
approaches that successfully address
faculty diversity and equity issues in
biomedical and behavioral science
departments
the prize is noteworthy because of how
it aligns with previous work in this
done both in and outside of mih
it's one of four concepts developed out
of the working group on women in
biomedical careers
it aligns with the national academies of
science engineering and medicine
promising practices report
and the nih
advisory committee to the director
working group on changing the culture to
end sexual harassment
recommendations as well as other nih
policy changes and programs
what exactly are the kinds of
interventions the prize has in mind they
could include interventions that address
barriers to career advancements and
hence pathways to leadership
establish equitable recruitment
practices change workplace culture or
implement mentoring structures work life
integration programs and career flexible
flexibility options
the coronavirus pandemic has wreaked
havoc on nearly every sector of society
and the economy
its impact has affected women in stem
fields
pandemic related household and
caregiving responsibilities
are interrupting research and
reducing publishing which can impede
advancement
the impact on early career investigators
is especially
devastating
women's departure and slowed advancement
will affect the direction of research
for many years
its impact is likely to change the face
and work of biomedical research
for years to
come so many hard-fought gains are now
at risk especially among women in
academia and stem fields
while many institutions have begun to
address the unique challenges that women
scientists face
more institutions must step up
to the plate
before i finish i would like to extend a
special thank you
to the unsung heroines of biomedical
research the women volunteers who
participate in clinical trials
usually at some expense and
inconvenience often at great risk to
their health these tens of thousands of
women have been indispensable to the
work of biomedical researchers
without them our knowledge base would be
a fraction of what it is today
thank you
the current pandemic underscores the
critical role of inclusion of women of
all backgrounds in clinical studies
with women being half of the population
and playing pivotal roles in society
these two questions are just not
academic ones
how does covid manifest itself in women
and how do women respond to therapies
the women who participate in coven 19
clinical trials will help us answer
those questions
and lastly i invite you to connect with
orwh online and through its many
communications channels
each issue of our quarterly publication
women's health in focus at nih covers a
core area of women's health research
from inclusion in the recent issue to
sabv to women in biomedical careers or
specific conditions that affect women
our monthly pulse email
keeps you up to date
on breaking developments of research at
orwh and nih's programs and of course
we're on social media please join us for
rich conversations about women's health
topics
since 1990 the nih office of research on
women's health has been at the forefront
of advancing biomedical research to
improve the health of women because of
orwh's leadership across nih and the
entire biomedical research enterprise
and because of its support of biomedical
research
women today are living longer healthier
lives
more work though needs to be done
for orwh the path forward holds great
promise with we believe that the more we
study sex and gender the better the
science and the better the science the
better the health of everyone
thank you
three minutes is nowhere near enough
time to adequately cover all the
contributions that our next speaker has
made to improving the health of women
scientific perspective dr francis
collins the director of the national
institutes of health is a giant among
the giants of biomedical research
after getting his ph.d in physical
chemistry at yale university and his
medical degree at the university of
north carolina dr collins made genetics
his area of concentration
he's noted for his groundbreaking
discoveries of disease-causing genetic
mutations and later his leadership of
the human genome project which came to a
spectacular conclusion in 2003 with the
completion of the finished sequence of
the human genome
for these achievements and a lifetime of
contributions to biomedical research dr
collins was awarded the presidential
medal of freedom in 2007 and received
the national medal of science in 2009
this year he was elected as a foreign
member of the royal society and in 2020
he was also named the 50th winner of the
templeton prize which celebrates
scientific and spiritual curiosity
under his leadership of nih there has
been a tremendous growth in the research
of women's health from maternal health
and breast
cancer cardiovascular disease and mental
health and everything in between
from head to toe and across the life
course nih has funded research that has
produced monumental work that has
contributed mightily to our
understanding of the diseases and
conditions that affect women
dr collins has also been a champion of
policies that have helped advance the
health of women
he's been a strong supporter of
increasing women's participation in
clinical trials as well as the
participation of other underrepresented
populations
dr collins has been a leader in
examining and improving the ways we
conduct science
i had the great privilege of
collaborating with dr collins on the
development of the nih policy on sexes
biological variable or what we call sabv
i look forward to our continued work on
implementing sabv across nih and
throughout the nia community
likewise
presence on or should i say against
mammals will lead to more opportunities
for women scientists to shine contribute
and be recognized
clear also has been his commitment to
the recruitment retention and
advancement of women and people of color
in biomedical research careers these are
just a few examples of his commitment to
a diverse scientific workforce as a
necessary means to producing
excellent science
finally on a personal level throughout
my 10 years overwatch director dr
collins has been a mentor a visionary
colleague and an ally
we at orwh have been so fortunate to
have an nih director with second to
achieving orwh's vision
a vision in which sex and gender
influences are integrated throughout the
biomedical research enterprise
every woman receives evidence-based
disease prevention and treatment
tailored to her own needs circumstances
and goals
and all women in science careers reach
their full potential
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen is my
honor to introduce the 16th director of
the national institutes of health dr
francis s collin
well thanks dr clayton
and thanks to everybody who has joined
today to celebrate 30 years of the
national institutes of health and its
office of research on women's health
anniversaries are a cause to celebrate
also to reflect to take stock as we look
forward
and of course covet 19 has managed to
interrupt a lot of these kinds of
celebrations but it will not prevent us
today from having this virtual moment to
see what has been accomplished
what still lies ahead and to
collectively celebrate these three
decades
of progress
a word about the history
orwh was formed in response to a growing
outcry
it could be called call for social
justice in that instance
the fact that women were
underrepresented in clinical research
and therefore conclusions were being
drawn based largely on research on men
that may or may not have been
appropriate for half the population
in the 1970s the 1980s citizens
scientists clinicians policy makers
coming to the same conclusion and
beginning to get some traction that the
health of women had been shortchanged
and something had to be done
and a wise step forward was the
formation of our own office of research
on women's health
in the early 1990s
dr bernadine healey who by the way
recruited me to nih through the genome
project
the first woman director of nih
she saw this as both an opportunity and
a responsibility and a mandate and in
1993
she launched the women's health
initiative one of the largest disease
prevention and clinical studies
ever conducted on women's health
this was challenging to put together
something at this scale
but the results have been stunning
they concluded in fact that hormone
treatments for women should be based on
research that includes women not merely
clinical assumptions
and the results have led to
126 000 fewer cases of breast cancer 76
000 fewer cases of cardiovascular
disease because of what we learned about
hormone treatments and when they're safe
and when they're not so think of all the
lives saved by that initiative
and putting on my economic hat for a
minute to also consider the economic
benefits
the women's health initiative has helped
save approximately 35 billion in direct
medical costs in the u.s so if you want
to do this return on investment
calculation for nih investment of
research that's about 140 to 1
for the money that was spent on this
research effort
pretty darn good investment and showing
the way to how these kinds of
initiatives focusing on sex differences
are not just a nice thing to do they are
essential
so orwh today continues to focus on
affecting transformational change
orwh is a leading voice
for sex differences research
and helping train the next generation of
researchers
to include that kind of
insight in whatever they do
and also to enact research changing
policy innovations
janine clayton and i focused on this
issue
particularly on the lack of rigor and
reproducibility in nih research and a
major part of that turned out to be
the failure to consider sex as a
biological variable in many animal model
experiments
and yet preclinical research relies on
that kind of experiment in order to
decide how to take things forward into
human application and if that had not
considered sex differences then you were
not well prepared for making that leap
into human applications
so we worked hard on that and put
forward a policy which has now been
embraced uh adopted enforced even
by nih that that is not just an option
it is absolutely essential in
pre-clinical studies of animals
that there be an understanding of sex
differences which means recording that
and making sure males and females are
included and that it is possible to be
able to see if there's a significant
difference that that doesn't just get
all swept together than some kind of
average binding
so when you start looking for sex
influences you're more likely to find
them and people have now been doing so
right and left
a recent study that really underlines
the biology here
relates to the program called gtex
that is funded by the common fund
gtex aims to look at
gene expression across
dozens of tissues in hundreds of rapid
autopsies in order to discern what is
the pattern of gene expression in the
human body and when you look at the
differences between men and women
they found
more than 13 000 genes that's a pretty
significant fraction of the total a
little over half that are expressed
differently
between the sexes
that clearly affects some 50 bodily
traits and functions so you simply can't
do
human research even if you think you're
just looking at something as basic as
gene expression without considering sex
differences it's a fundamental part of
how biology works i guess we sort of
knew that but yet sometimes it got
pushed aside in an effort to try to
carry out experiments
that didn't really have that kind of
consideration
about sex differences
orwh is determined to make sure
that people don't make that mistake
on top of the way in which orwh has
played its role
in
making sure that the science pays
attention to sex differences
they've also been very important in
advancing women to leadership roles in
the sciences and throughout the
biomedical research workforce and i've
been uh fortunate to be an ally in this
effort in my 11 years as nih director
working with the nih working group on
women in biomedical careers which i
co-chair with janine coming up with a
wide variety of approaches to try to
understand why we still
seem to have difficulties with
appropriate promotion retention and
advancement of women to senior positions
even though we're doing better in terms
of women receiving doctoral degrees in
the life sciences
for my part i've tried to do what i can
to emphasize the importance of women
leaders in other ways i announced a year
and a half ago and got a lot more
attention than i expected that i would
no longer take part
in symposia
or
meeting panels that were composed
entirely of men so-called mantles
which unfortunately often seem to be the
case when people simply weren't thinking
about the fact that there's a great deal
of talent and diversity and yet often
times that talent was not well
represented in those gatherings and
so-called mantles and hymposia became
too often the norm well
i've stuck to that i don't think i've
made any mistakes in the last year and a
half and it's been really interesting
because when i get sent an invitation
the first question is okay what is the
diversity uh in your symposium or your
panel of participation and if the answer
doesn't look as if they got it
about the essential nature of diversity
both of women and of underrepresented
groups then they get a message back that
says dr collins thinks your meeting
sounds interesting but he will not be
able to attend
unless you pay more attention to this
issue
and you know most of the reactions at
that point are pretty interesting it's
not that they say oh you're just like
one of those people going to make us do
something we don't want to do no they go
you know you're right
we just i guess we didn't think about
this so maybe by this little triggering
of the thought process uh something can
happen i would encourage all of you who
are involved in meetings and symposia to
take that same approach
and the differences can be significant
and the way in which this influences the
richness of our scientific conversation
should not be understated
and of course when it comes to
recruiting leaders i also have had a
chance as nih director to recruit new
institute directors
since we have 27 institutes and centers
and the average time for somebody to
stay on board
is in the neighborhood of a decade so
over this time there have been turnovers
and i'm very happy to tell you that now
we have no less than 10 of our 27
institutes and centers that are women by
far the largest number in our history
and i'd love to see it go even a little
higher
so we're trying to do everything we can
to encourage women's participation in
clinical research the importance of
diversity
uh one final thing i would just say the
all of us program which is enrolling one
million americans in the most ambitious
long-term cohort study on health and
illness
is has as one of its major defining
points attention to diversity
so it will be both sex balanced roughly
50 50 and also will have reached out and
has reached out in the first 380 000
participants uh to enroll participants
from racial and ethnic groups that are
traditionally underrepresented as well
as people from rural communities as well
as people who are of lower socioeconomic
status
and lower educational level groups that
often don't get included we want that to
be a signature aspect of all of us and
the team that is doing that has
succeeded that in ways that i think are
really quite impressive
so here we are in orwh's 30th year
a year that has been marked of course by
something else called covet 19 which is
forced a lot of us to carry out our
mission in fashions that we hadn't quite
anticipated yes i'm speaking to you from
my home office at chevy chase where i've
kind of been holed up since march trying
to run nih
but people have been remarkably willing
to drop everything and figure out how to
make that work and boy if i
had any doubts about the dedication of
the biomedical research community to
rise to the occasion to rise to a
challenge to stick to their noble
enterprise of trying to figure out a way
to make the world a better place they
have all done that this year in
remarkable partnerships collaborations
just to make every possible scientific
advance happen as quickly as it possibly
could and here we are now
in a circumstance where vaccines are
going to be
in the arms of high-risk people even
before the end of 2020 something that
one could not have imagined a few years
ago because this
generally would be a 10-year project and
instead it's been done in less than a
year
that should give us
enthusiastic hope and optimism that we
can do other things faster than anybody
thought and when there were some lessons
here that we will need to incorporate
into how nih does things
but most of all i think we want to do
things in the fashion that is right and
good and that means paying attention to
sex differences
doing the best possible rigorous
research to help uh all of those folks
who are out there waiting for us to come
up with answers to medical conditions
that haven't yet really been sorted out
orwh is a critical part of that
and so finally i just want to say thank
you to all of you who've been part of
this adventure the adventure will
continue we're marking this milestone
and then preparing for what's next
we have a lot of potentially exciting
science to do going forward to improve
the health of women that is what i am
dedicated to and i know you are as well
so thank you and
30 years wow celebrate
i'm celebrating with you although i wish
i could be there in person
to do it maybe next year on the 31st
we'll have a better chance for that
many thanks
[Music]
since 1990 the nih office of research on
women's health has been dedicated
specifically to promoting women's health
research
the office has served as the focal point
at nih for research relevant to the
health of women and has promoted and
supported women's health research in the
greater biomedical community as well
one of the most important developments
of the past 30 years has been the
transformation of the term women's
health from a narrow focus on maternal
and reproductive health to a broader
holistic and multi-dimensional concept
involving the health of women from head
to toe and across their lifespans
orwh is addressing the complex
intersection of factors that affect
women's health from biological variables
to gender roles policies and social
determinants of health
this transformation evolved over many
years during the 1960s the civil and
women's rights movements gave rise to
the women's health movement which drew
attention to inequities in research and
health care
later a series of drug recalls revealed
that many drugs posed greater health
risks to women than to men moreover
nearly all medications were tested only
in men
the scientific community took note and
responded led by forward-thinking
leaders such as bernadine healey ruth
kerstein vivian penn and later orwh's
current director janine clayton and nih
director francis collins
congress ii pressed for change
also influential were patient advocacy
organizations research institutions
medical societies and women's health
groups
in the late 1980s and 90s nih adopted
inclusion policies that accelerated the
movement toward a multi-dimensional
approach to women's health a few years
later the nih revitalization act of 1993
required the inclusion of women and
minorities in nih-funded clinical
research today about half of
participants in nih clinical trials are
women
more recently the 21st century cures act
required nih to revise its policy on the
inclusion of children in clinical
research expanding the policy to include
individuals of all ages
but inclusion didn't go far enough
for women to receive optimal clinical
care clinicians need to understand how
sex and gender affect disease
manifestation diagnosis and treatment
in 2016 the nih's landmark sex as a
biological variable policy the
development of which was led by orwh
further advanced women's health by
helping to ensure that the potential
influences of sex on health and disease
are considered early and throughout the
research process
this work also helps advance women's
health toward a holistic
multi-dimensional framework
through the years orwh's signature
research programs have added to the body
of knowledge that is informing this
approach to women's health
among these are
the building interdisciplinary research
careers in women's health or birch
program
a trans nih collaborative effort
launched in 2000 that connects junior
faculty to senior faculty with shared
interest in women's health and sex
differences research
the specialized centers of research
excellence on sex differences or score
program which translates scientific
knowledge about how diseases affect
women and men differently into new
treatments that improve clinical care
the u3 program nih is only program
focused on researching health
disparities among populations of women
that have been understudied
underrepresented and under-reported in
biomedical research
nih's first research project grant that
focuses on sex and gender in health and
disease
and orwh funded research and programs
that are addressing pressing issues
women currently face such as maternal
morbidity and mortality and opioid use
disorder
supporting the advancement of women in
biomedical careers has been a key aspect
of orwh's mission
the office has also played a vital role
in supporting a diverse biomedical
research workforce including both women
and men that addresses the health of
women
in 2007 nih director elia zarhooni
established the working group on women
in biomedical careers its landmark
causal factors and interventions
initiative produced research that has
expanded opportunities and reduced
barriers for women in biomedical
research
this diversity has produced better
science
studies show that women researchers are
more likely to study sex as a biological
variable further expanding the knowledge
base of sex effects diversity among
researchers also helps generate more
innovation
over the years orwh has supported
critical trans nih and extramural
research that has profoundly increased
our understanding of women's health and
produced groundbreaking clinical
interventions
among this work are the women's health
initiative the study of women's health
across the nation and numerous
discoveries that have dramatically
reduced breast cancer death rates led to
the hpv vaccine
and more recently contributed to the
development of a 3d modeling system of
the female reproductive organs tract
the path forward holds great promise
since 1990 orwh supported research
policy innovations and career programs
have helped to expand the knowledge base
and produce better science
and by working to broaden the concept of
women's health to include all diseases
and conditions that affect the health of
women from head to toe and across the
life course orwh is helping to improve
the health of women and the families and
communities to which they belong
you